[Musik]
hallo wünsche front
eine der höchsten auszeichnungen die wir
im ein herr zu vergeben haben der sich
unser es orte gold schließt die ist
natürlich kein geringerer der diesen
orden bekommt als unser zunftmeister am
ort der markus gast als erwartet was
passiert wenn der bin fertig ist und in
jeder hier gesehen
es gibt mit sicherheit 1 mehr leute wo
damit ein problem haben hier aber das
wird sich wieder dem keiner denkt ich
wollte es komplett von mir abwenden wenn
ich mal zumindest offen markus ist
vorstand im fastnachts fallen dem
größten verein hier in meinem heimatdorf
und markus hat ein geheimnis er ist
schwul
seit jahren hält der 54-jährige diesen
teil seines lebens vor der
dorfgemeinschaft versteckt
ich selber bin auch hier aufgewachsen
ich weiß wie es ist hier zu leben und
nicht der norm zu entsprechen
doch trotzdem oder gerade deshalb bin
ich davon überzeugt markus würde es
besser gehen würde er sich endlich von
der last seines geheimnisses befreien
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
heiligenberg so heißt dieses 2000 seelen
dorf im hinterland des bodensees
der name passt tatsächlich ist ja noch
ein stück heile welt doch wie in vielen
kleinen dörfern ist die kehrseite dieser
ländlichen idylle dass dinge die in
städten schon längst zum alltag gehören
für manche menschen hier noch immer ein
tabu sind
ausnahmezustand herrschte einmal im jahr
an fasnacht immer vorneweg markus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fasnacht dauert hier über eine woche und
beginnt traditionell mit dem stellen des
narrenbaums neben ausgelassener
fröhlichkeit geht es hier auch manchmal
etwas der aber zu der männer und mars
ist eine wanderung durch die gemeinde
von wirtschaft zur wirtschaft eine frau
habe ich gleich sie einzeln aus und
schlägt immer so wenn der so viel die
endlos posten haben entsteht es das
ganze jahr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gerade an solchen tagen denke ich mir
muss es für markus besonders schwer sein
dieses doppelleben zu führen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fasnacht ist ein brauch den oft nur
diejenigen verstehen die damit
aufgewachsen sind so wie ich lebe zwar
nicht mehr hier
ich arbeite in zürich beim fernsehen
doch zur fasnacht komme ich jedes jahr
heiligenberg ist nicht nur mein
heimatdorf sondern immer noch heimat für
mich die markus gefällt auch mir das
leben in dieser gemeinschaft was sicher
auch mit meiner familiengeschichte
zusammenhängt der auf dem bild hinter
mir das ist mein großvater er war 25
jahre lang narrenpräsident der vorgänger
von markus in die fasnacht wird man eben
rhein geboren
ein sprichwort das auf mich perfekt
zutrifft
schon meine mutter kann direkt hier im
dorf auf die welt mit 16 in der hippie
zeit suchte sie die freiheit
sie gingen nach rotterdam und lernte
meinen vater einen surinam erkennen
mein bruder und ich kam auf die welt und
wir lebten ein paar jahre zusammen in
heiligenberg ist es meinen vater er war
seemann wieder in den nächsten hafen zog
[Musik]
mein bruder und ich wuchsen dann als die
beiden einzigen dunkelhäutigen im ganzen
umkreis hier auf
mit allem was dazugehört
[Musik]
ich selber habe mich im dorf immer sehr
wohl gefühlt
doch ich weiß von meiner mutter die
heute noch erlebt dass es gerade zu
beginn nicht immer einfach war und wie
war es somit uns dunkelhäutige kinder
hier in einem kleinen dorf im
kindergarten real gab es schon kleine
bemerkungen von andere kinder halt ein
mädchen hat haydn hinter euch berghofer
anwalt fragt ob er es zuerst daheim an
der anderen seite erfindet die kinder
das jetzt muss ja irgendwie von der heim
kommen denke ich es gab auch solche die
mal irgendwie lego niveau im bereich
hair group unterhalt dieser begriff
toilette tief taucht einmal auftaucht
ist das naturrecht ganz brutal sich ein
herz für kinder glaub das ist ja normal
das muss ich ja wenn da einer brille hat
hat noch irgendwas risiko wenn eine
dickere wo halt damals fand es ganz
schlimm weil ich habe immer irgendwie
gedacht könnte bisschen beitrag zur
völkerverständigung leisten indem ich
euch auf die welt brachte aber wenn man
dann so was gehört hat hat man sich dann
schon auch überlegt vielleicht war ich
da gerade angefangen mit tun haben wenn
die leute denken trotzdem
die schönen erinnerungen an meine
kindheit überwiegen
die menschen hier haben sich irgendwann
einfach an uns gewöhnt und gar nicht
mehr gemerkt dass wir anders aussehen
[Musik]
ich bin sicher auch an die tatsache dass
markus schwul ist würden sich die
meisten menschen schnell gewöhnen
also fraglich markus letzten sommer ob
ich ein porträt über ihn machen könne
meine mutter der toleranten im dorf
hatte er sich einst zu später stunde an
der fasnacht theke anvertraut was ich
sonst über ihn wusste war dass er
inhaber eines kleinen handwerksbetriebes
ist den sein ur ur großvater gegründet
hat er war verheiratet hat zwei
erwachsene töchter mit denen er sich gut
versteht und lebt seit zwölf jahren
allein in diesem haus das er einst für
seine familie gebaut hatte was ich nicht
wusste wie gehe ich dieses sensible
thema an über dass markus so lange
geschwiegen hat
[Musik]
zum einbeziehen stadt und sagt man so
schön in facebook beziehungsstatus
single wenn beziehung dann kompliziert
[Gelächter]
ja warum beziehungsstatus kompliziert
ganz einfach weil man eine kleine dorf
lebe wo jeder jeden kennt stehen
umschrieben
warum ist das kompliziert das ist ja
noch kein und
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in dem schreiben das fahrzeug im buch
gesagt hat du kannst so interessant
macht
das geht leider nicht
spätestens nach diesem interview war
auch für markus klar um was es in meinem
film gehen soll
doch er sagte mir er sei sich noch nicht
sicher ob er sich tatsächlich outen will
trotzdem war es für ihn kein problem
dass ich ihn mit der kamera zum
christopher street day in zwei stunden
entfernte stuttgart begleitet
solange er es nicht aussprechen sei noch
nichts bewiesen
[Musik]
seit zehn jahren besucht markus diese
spur lesbische paraden ohne jemandem
davon zu erzählen
[Musik]
ich bin mir sicher viele menschen hier
in heiligenberg hätten gar kein problem
mit seiner homosexualität vorauszusagen
wie die leute tatsächlich reagieren ist
aber leider unmöglich
auch wenn man glaubt sie gut zu kennen
besuch bei seiner mutter
meine schwester hat einmal gesagt wie
duschen du bitte markus hübschen bloß
scharf abend er kuscht show er hatte
doch wissen was los ich warten bis er
hat eigentlich weniger schlecht braucht
sein zumal die patina die hat manchmal
reißt fordert als jugend ist dann darf
dann einmal wilderer zeit oder war immer
ein ganz brav
ja es hat genau wenn wir nie alles
[Gelächter]
eigentlich bild ich bin der zeit
entsprechend modernen browser
[Musik]
irgendwie war mir in der familie weiß
über mich an sich ja blöd viele wissen
über mich geschaut ja aber vielleicht
nicht offiziell von mir kundgetan ja
viele fans aber man spricht im prinzip
nicht drüber
manche hier weil es irgendwie besser wir
die kein geheimnis wenn es kein
geheimnis mehr wer es mir ob es mir
besser gehen weiß ich nicht
ich denk mal ist dort viel verwirrung
ich habe das gefühl markus hat sich im
lauf der jahre mit seiner situation
arrangiert vielleicht kann ich ihnen
durch die arbeit am film zumindest dazu
anregen noch mal über andere optionen
nachzudenken
[Gelächter]
ich hatte gelesen gran canaria sei einen
schwulen hotspot und markus kurzerhand
vorgeschlagen seinen urlaub hier zu
verbringen
[Musik]
am letzten tag der reise hat markus eine
eigene idee für das ende des films
was er denn jetzt für mich selber nicht
unbedingt weil ja gut klar dass sie auch
mal elbe kann die zeit ja aber
eigentlich eher für andere mal sehen
es geht doch auch anders geht es
einfacher mache es gern leute die in der
gleichen situation also in der gleichen
situation
ich hatte vorhin gehofft dass er diese
aufbruchsstimmung auch mit nach hause
nimmt
[Musik]
doch nur wenige wochen später am ende
einer fasnacht die ohne besondere
vorkommnisse verlief team der funke
schon wieder verflogen und alles beim
alten zu sein
und der tut und macht und kraft hat um
das ganze durchzuziehen und ist einfach
und dafür viele vielen dank markus die
jungen präsidenten vorstände so etwas
begutachtet worden und tauche krise
wolle dass sie etwas frech nach frauen
umschau halten sollte
und jetzt haben wir einige funde so
gerne mal so eine hübsche ich will bloß
sagen wir können etwas helfen da geht
immer einfach dir einmal die vorstelle
wie heißt aber nicht gebrochen was er
von seiner mutter und gedreht hat dann
ist die wahnsinnig nett und willst du
ein kuchen und hier und da und jetzt
passiert wenn sie mir hier trifft
unterwegs
ach ja gut als dass es krieg muss ich
das kriege ich doch gebacken bis dahin
ja du musst also dass das ist mir
ermöglicht eine herzensangelegenheit
dass du ihr das vorher sagst du sonst ja
aber sie muss wissen dass es dann
öffentlich werden problem ja klar das
wort selber habe ich zb aussprechen
[Gelächter]
also ich auch nicht hier geht es um die
frage ist der cache ist nicht schwul ist
es raus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
nach einem jahr dreharbeiten sind wir
nicht mehr nur vereinskollegen sondern
freunde geworden
mir wird bewusst wie viel man bewegen
kann wenn man dinge einfach anspricht
anstatt sie totzuschweigen
mit seiner mutter möchte markus aber
verständlicherweise persönlich sprechen
ohne kamera team
weil sie eigentlich was also soll
erstens normale geschichte voraus wo
markus gaugisch war ja dass auch im
gespräch war aber noch nicht so
also ich sie dort kein unterschied
er ist trotzdem ein sehr wohl ich denke
halt wenn das jemand hat wo er glücklich
ist mit egal ob so oder so das sagen hat
so lange gewartet hat das zu sagen ja
und das ist mein kopf will sich
wahnsinnig schwer gefallen ich bis zum
st
zwar war die zahl ständig vielleicht
reift das ist mal ein neues muster
vielleicht ein paar jahre zu spät aber
gut wenn du bist was es letztendlich so
einfach ist so nachhinein klaus springer
schloss fällt jetzt führungsoffizier
gesagt kann es ist ein leben
so hat diese geschichte tatsächlich ein
happy end
ich hätte mir noch gewünscht dass markus
sich vor dem ganzen dorf auto doch er
fragte mich wie so etwas tun solle
wer etwas wissen möchte sollte ihn
fragen dann bekäme er eine antwort
[Musik]
und es stimmt wieso sollte er sich dafür
rechtfertigen dass er nicht der
konservativen norm entspricht
es liegt an der mehrheit und nicht an
der minderheit heimaten zu schaffen wo
jeder mensch so leben kann wie er
geboren ist